quand des collectivités ont organisé des
référendums sur des grands sujets
notamment des fermetures d'entreprises
on leur a dit ça n'est pas de votre
compétence donc le problème c'est pas de
de dire que cette démocratie locale et
inutile c'est de constater que son chant
est extrêmement limitée et que en fait
sur les grandes questions on a pas de
débat démocratique cercle le débat se
fait dans le meilleur des cas à paris
est bien plus souvent à bruxelles et je
pense que si le mouvement des gilets
jaunes a autant insister sur la
reconquête de la démocratie c'est parce
que on veut plus de ça et moi la
question qui m'intéresse c'est comment
est ce que la démocratie locale
permettrait de s'emparer de tous les
sujets pas seulement voilà de comment
est-ce qu'on aménage la rue ou est-ce
qu'il faut créer un stade de foot ou
déplacer le cimetière et je pense que la
démocratie locale pourrait servir à
poser les grands débats de société à
condition qu'on ait une vraie réflexion
sur les institutions qu'ils aillent du
local au national mais ça évidemment ça
va se heurter aussi au fait qu'on a un
certain nombre d'élus notamment dans les
grandes villes qui est bien bénéficie
d'institutions qui leur donne quasiment
les pleins pouvoirs parce que en matière
de démocratie les institutions sont
faites de telle façon que au niveau
d'une municipalité vous pouvez très bien
gérée en autocrate et que rien ne vous
oblige à consulter la population et que
vous pouvez très bien considéré que vous
êtes élu les pires vous revenez six ans
après pour voir si des gens feraient
satisfait et je pense que on devrait
revendiquer des mécanismes obligatoire
de démocratie locale
parce que ce que vous défendez ça ne
devrait pas être laissée au bon vouloir
des élus c'est quelque chose qui devrait
être pratiquée dans toutes les villes et
dans toutes les communes de france
[Musique]